guys I got bad news you might want to
sit down how do I even begin to say this
all my dr. Phil videos got claimed by so
many TV they stroked out of nowhere
I wasn't even from here you know dr.
Feld wore my t-shirt so I thought he was
a pro okay I thought he would appreciate
my videos and understand that he gave
traction to his show but this of course
means no more dr. Phil videos I know I'm
crying too and I have been crying this
is a big app a massive F no mind of G
fuel in the world is gonna solve this
problem I know it but instead we're
gonna have to wash them god damn it cuz
I got nothing else planned
now dr. Philly if you're listening I'm
not man okay I'm just disappointed and
I'm waiting I'm waiting for my apology
and retraction okay Sony ATV publishing
do you know what fair use is huh hit the
remains but never make why is the camera
so close in the meanwhile we're gonna
have to review tick-tock so let's just
freakin do this people keep saying that
I look scared like there's a person
behind the camera holding you gonna be
no you look like a wolf okay
goddamnit sorry I'm upset I am upset
let's see some good tick-tock let's get
some really good tic TOCs to share me up
Oh time today I know we haven't set off
yet why is 2013 jacksepticeye in my
tick-tock be be God Irish man I don't
want you there's a time and place for
everything
but not now this guy got 340 thousand
likes just for moving his hands probing
you need to be good looking to get likes
when do something I'm that good-looking
guy oh well well played
I guess Eisen of the Builder it won't
look like a leaf you don't think all
these ticked are kids they all look the
same
Wow incredible
their production quality of these have
really increased massively that must
have taken forever we can't even do that
with the green screen look hey you got
the drugs of course I got the drug what
is Brad doing in my tick-tock beat get
out of here man first leaf week them
jack
now Brad what the Frick is going on not
a cop are you
of course not are you sure cuz if you're
a cop you have to tell me does he have a
septum ring damn Brian
I didn't take you for a little no he
just has a big nose
sorry it's minecraft don't eat it out of
the can by the way I'm just really
desperate
yeah I only had a dog don't ever hit a
dog I don't care if it's in Minecraft
that actually makes it worse you lost my
respect
tick tock community I can't even eat G
fuel now I'm so angry
The Incredible Hulk be like hope
my spine okay that was great guys I
don't buy you but that was freaking
crane balling is not funny okay whoa
holy wow that's so happy
he opened the fridge that's that's funny
that's really [ __ ] funny
I'm laughing I'm actually laughing don't
judge me okay I don't need judgment I'm
having a rough day
oh my dr. Phil did all your dr. Phil
videos get claimed I don't think so okay
I don't understand I don't understand
how he can do this
you can't just plain videos what's he
doing put in for your other camera yeah
and then no I'm sick and tired of
everyone saying that Andrew dad's bed
quality look at my camera quality I use
an Android it's excellent thank you very
much y'all just a bunch of lazy and
whatever it's called keep up with the
kids guys I'm under crisis so my
pewdiepie wall matter for 49 days now
and I kind of want as it should by the
way if you don't have a pewdiepie wall I
got bad news for you you might as well
go unsubscribe right now because that
subscription means nothing unless you
have at least a PewDiePie altar with a
candle or an anime girl or something god
damn accuse the one deal to not take it
down though
don't take it'll be a challenge but I
need 10,000 likes to not to get down so
good luck
well you might think this is pretty
cheap attempt to get likes but I think
it's worth it
smash like on this video guys you heard
the man 10,000 likes can we do it keep
that altar up
do you subscribe to PewDiePie what is
raise your eyebrow if you did Wow
incredible amazing absolutely are these
guys how do you even get your hair like
that and why wave check memes are not
funny okay why they're racist oh I mean
I mean I'm a Native American
we have brilliant wavy the hell are you
saying I'm so confusing or not I can't
tell
wavy shake memes are epic not funny
these people are just trying to bait out
to like troll them it's so not epic okay
I know what you're doing mr. Native
American okay nobody yeah I've been nice
to be kind of me considerate of them I
got you guys like laughter funny ha ha
do it with me
why you should subscribe to t-series 10
reasons why t-series is better than P
[Music]
we're supposed to be on the same side 10
reasons I can't think of a single reason
- 10 reason I can't see I cannot find it
they actually believe it or it is it
fake jaw prayer-book oh god it's it's
about to hit zero it hit what thank you
job prayer what in the world well we
have tick talkers on our side I guess
Jesus Christ how is he not passed yet
every time it looks like it's gonna pass
it just goes back up again I don't get
it I mean hell yeah I'll take it play
keV yo what's going on
I've got Laennec my tight arms slapping
hit this will be easy I extend my arm
open my grip and brace for impact
wait what is he yeah what is he doing
he's going for a fist bump and I'm
already in Phase three
there's still time if I can close my
grip and decrease my extension velocity
by 40% then I can catch him on the
downswing
after that it's just a matter of oh that
was great
this is what people don't understand I
have an excellent handshake a lot of
people say oh you don't have a good
handshake it's absolutely incredible hit
me up with anything I will be able to
counter it because I'm always ten steps
ahead this would never happen to me
always is another meme of a short people
okay first of all five eleven wait how
come I 511 180 that's what I don't even
at me 511 is really tall okay
[Music]
yeah six feet okay got it six feet hey
look at six feet this is [ __ ] this
is discrimination and this is true
racism in my opinion okay I don't know
if I stand by those words yet let me
just think about it a little bit but for
now this is I'm sick of it my head's not
broken it's just this right I got a
healthy body but shitty brains I'm good
at rapping fast I can't accept you don't
even talk about this and why does she
look like sands okay I'm just throwing
that one in there as well she looks a
hell of a lot like saying that's a lot
is it intentional being placed in front
of a window cuz then I can respect it
otherwise it's just pure cringe if she
started going that would be a funny joke
just trying to have kids out I
understand that it's not a funny joke
but it's an ironic funny joke okay let
me just clear on that here's my
playstation is bared in xbox just let
you know I've only played for two years
I've been playing since halo 2 so I've
played more time on Xbox that I have
PlayStation here being a don't get mad
smaller and lighter console better
controller an incredibly simple home
screen that has never changed Xbox I
mean that is a good point actually I
can't even count them all you Xbox
players think you're so clever with your
backwards compatibility in game pass
well we have PlayStation now which is
our game pass and backwards
compatibility in one VR it's a faster
console and actually pretty decent
camera more and better exclusives than
just halo this pathetic fools these
cowards that play console games when you
can have an Origin PC excellent computer
10 out of 10 baby really maximize the
potential you know don't even at me with
a console
what are you poor they're real poor
everyone is like oh you're poor if you
have don't have a hair cause know you're
poor if you have a gaming console let's
get real here and let me stop my step
they're not poor just pathetic just
pathetic
oh god what is gonna
[Music]
[Music]
you know we're getting desperate when
we're doing this [ __ ] it started off
with posters and it ends with just pure
this is me one day on steroids this is
me one week on steroids okay this is
good oh my god everyone keep saying that
I'm Orange clearly I'm white can you not
tell that I'm white orange is not even a
race I'm clearly at the white race not
an orange so I don't understand that
comment below from orange or white cuz
I'm clearly white alright well I think
that about does it
thank you guys so much for another epic
video I don't know what I'm thinking you
you should be thanking me smash like
subscribe buy all the merch very nice
now everyone tweet my mane dr. Phil
let's get they spread please I need
these copy strikes to get removed I
thought we had something special dr.
Phil please do not disappoint and that's
it for now because otherwise this is all
we have and it ain't good what cheaper
simulators becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something yes this game is still
relevant
dear me